all right on to day three a wise man
once said
never over engineer your code
i'm sure some wise man said that i'm
just not sure who
because i just kind of made that up
all right so on the whole restructure
of this game engine
it is truly truly a mess right now i
tend to do this every new version or on
version zero zero six
right now is what we're working on and
oh my is it
yeah you know what's going on if you're
watching the episodes but i've been
still working on the window and setting
up some some bass stuff
and the bass functions and they're
coming along i still definitely have
some work to do
i've got the callback system worked out
uh for the most part i still have a lot
to add of course
but i decided to separate out receivers
so that they could be shared among the
interface portions that need to do stuff
to update other stuff yeah it's it's
kind of a convoluted thing
but i feel like doing it like this they
can each at least have
individual access and not have to pull
down a whole struct because one thing i
want to avoid is having to do this on
every callback because that is going to
get
weird and bad for the caching i believe
so to just have a small pointer
of a shared pointer to be able to pass
around a little bit it's going to be
maybe a better option than pulling down
these whole options and
and all this stuff
so that's maybe the intention here and
we'll see about getting rid of this i
might just make this window height
pin width somewhere else
but they do need to be tied to each
window since we're going to support
multiple multiple windows and now i'm
getting really close to the first test
of running this so basically we want to
be able to instantiate instances of the
engine which are an instance of the run
and
each one comes with a window a whole set
of functions a run and we're going to
have some private methods for update and
render and stuff like that so we're
getting close to being able to do that
and i've got some front end functions
i'm keeping it really simple to start
like we have the ability to initialize a
new instance
and
that's so that's public anything here
yeah and initialize a new instance and
and
the ability to run
which is just gonna run the first
instance
is what i'm thinking here and then if
you have multiple up you can just go
click on the other windows to switch to
those instances so it'll just kind of by
default start on the first instance
and uh yeah what i'm thinking here is
always do that and then just if there
are more they'll show up and you can go
click on them or switch to them via your
windowing
system and the wall tab action or
whatever
so
that's what i'm kind of thinking here
it's
not working
yeah so basically
some weird logic there yeah all a big
work in progress
and most of this
model code here
is uh commented out for the most part
because we just want to get some core
cases going and then we'll go from there
so yeah i think that's all i've got at
the moment that's still a lot of this is
still temporary i don't know if i'm
going to do this i want to do instances
of the list rather than a vector because
the way it grows
it's gonna be better and there's so
there's not gonna be many instances like
i can't imagine a scenario where anyone
would have more than three
up or
i guess if
okay let's do a little theory here what
if people want to design
say some kind of massive um calculation
interface and they want to put it on six
monitors the point of this is you can do
that you can
render your graphs or whatever somewhere
you can render something else somewhere
else so i kind of want to give it that
kind of support
where you could just
launch so many instances do something
really elaborate maybe you're like i
don't know say
some kind of trader or something and you
want to monitor a lot of things and you
want to build your own software that
does it all in one but you need multiple
windows and
and you want to be able to
uh
organize those as you want so you could
design each one launch them all that
that sort of thing i know that sounds
like crazy complicated but believe me
it'll make sense
later if this all works as i'm thinking
anyway
all right
well
restructuring code that used to work
to do something completely new is it's
crazy
and it's fun i love doing it it it
really gets my brain tingling
but keep in mind here that this isn't
exactly that risky i could always just
go back to an old branch where
everything works so that's the power of
version control as you always have those
old versions so i never feel bad
for starting a new branch and just
completely wrecking everything not not
wrecking wrecking like tearing it down
so you can build it back up sort of
thing and and make it not even
necessarily make sense to another branch
but that's a whole other topic
all right well after doing some
of research and testing i've got it to a
state where it will
initialize and here's what i'm thinking
here now this is going to be super nerdy
so
be your warrant be warned
plenty warned all right here we go
the code the code the code all right so
we want a list of instances like i was
talking about before
however
we need to be able to pass it when
options
are which is the window options that way
the user can have their own
specifications every time they
initialize a new window and this is also
something that can be modified on the
fly
uh through like you know end game
options so to speak and some of them
might require a restart but we'll have
to analyze that later i don't want to
get sidetracked all right so they can
initialize with options that's the point
and it's going to in place back
a new instance which is going to call
the constructor of instance every time
we add one now i took out all this stuff
because we're not using it yet we're
going to add it in as needed for the
functional loops
for now all we want to do is just get a
window popping up and see if we can
get that all sorted out very nice right
okay so we can initialize it with
nothing and that's fine uh
okay didn't mean to push that button
that's super fine if we initialize it
with nothing it just sets
up a new window
with a null pointer
go to window
and basically all that's going to do is
pass in this default constructor
which will
make our default options
and since this is null or we'll skip
over the whole copy block because we
want to make a deep copy of user
preferred options if they want that way
they're now stored in our window
now what this does mean that's sort of
awkward
is whatever the user created you know
they created some windows options to
initialize with if they did that
then
their copy should be deleted afterwards
or let it go out of scope or whatever
and that's fine now this is not thread
safe because of that too
i believe
all right but if we do make a deep copy
now it just saves everything into our
windows options
very good so it's essentially like a
windows options constructor
we could push all this code off into
the windows options
but we'll uh not worry about that right
now because i want this to kind of
have some control over that then we go
to the default init which is fine it and
it's with these options
okay so we got that sorted out but
so you can well yeah so from the
front-end uter interface
now where that was the back-end now
we're going to
the front end this is the front end yes
it's all commented out so you can
initialize new instance and you can run
that's that's what we're starting with
here
on this uh
three structure because we want to yeah
we're just scaffolding right now
basically right all right init new
instance
you can pass it pass it windows options
to do so
and then
it'll set up that whole window with the
rendering system all that and then you
can run it now the next thing we want to
do is be able to
manage these instances
so we're going to start with running one
and that's all it's going to do just
make sure there's one and runs the first
one that's all it's going to do
basically
and run in this case on this instance
that's going to start our all our
processing looping all that
and
should the user
make more instances
what should run do
well we want to make sure it initializes
properly first of all make sure it pops
up a new window properly wrong button
again
and and get all its options
on its own side
and that way
we'll make uh let's see where are our
callbacks callbacks we're going to make
a click call back at some point uh
not that one not that one say on this
one on window focus callback so whatever
window you click
we need to switch to that instance
so this is going to get a little tricky
but we'll get it figured out
pretty darn soon thanks for watching
[Music]
you